what's coming from my heart right now is
maybe you're watching this and saying
hmm maybe I need to hedge you know if
you work from eating p.m. to 4:00 in the
morning will your dreams come true
no you might not be good enough you
might have not picked the right product
but are we living in a world in 2012
it's so much better than your parents
and grandparents and great grandparents
generation because [ __ ] like me can
make videos when I'm thirty thousand
[ __ ] feet in the air yes and because
of that and because of those
opportunities because we're networks in
a way we've never seen before because
having an email to 100 people and one
will answer and give you a shot matters
because of that opportunity because of
2012 I beg you I beg you to take a shot
let me tell you a thing I don't talk
about a whole lot that I've talked about
a little bit if you really follow me
which is the following in my 20s I spent
an enormous amount of time hanging out
with 90 year old people a lot there was
a strategy I was like [ __ ] it these
people did it right let's see what they
have to say what happened last night
in Soho London I'm watching you on
periscope you know you kind of had this
flash mob and you put it out on snapchat
yes and hundreds of people were there
like on a Tuesday night at 10:30 last
night was something I probably will it's
funny I've told the team I like I will
fundamentally on remember this night my
whole life last night I did something I
haven't done a long time early Twitter
2007-2008 I could tweet and say I'm
going to a pizza shop and you know 20
people would show up and it'd be
incredible obviously I'm doing a big
book signing event in London today and I
show a lot of people tweeting and
snapping and instagramming that they
were disappointed that they couldn't
make it so I'm like you know what put
out on snapchat hey tonight after dinner
you know I'm gonna go pick some spot
come and meet me 10 p.m. so whole area
more D Delta Company and I put that on
snapchat and Instagram and we sat and
had dinner and I said we were debating
how many people would show up if I would
have tweeted this I mean you saw it
this has been more time but like that
seven or eight would have been twenty
and missus now and you know I was like
man of fifty people show up then I feel
like my brand is really doing something
like something's happening here there's
250 300 people it was complete insanity
it was super humbling I mean it started
at 10:30 at night we were there till
1:30 in the morning people literally
stood there for an hour and a half two
hours three hours just to take a selfie
or ask a question the boss is my
business Barry 75 years old I go he's
[ __ ] on fire I can text them right now
it's [ __ ] me like what like 75 like
you got minimum minimum 20 prime years
forget about years crime um I don't even
I I don't even know how to put into
words the level of gratitude and
humility that you have to feel as a
human being that in a couple of hours in
a country you don't live in that people
would show up to that level it was a
super cool night for me man I'm just
glad I got to have this conversation
because I've dated so many times thank
you brother thank you so much man that
was an interesting moment with those two
girls like like like what do you want
because if you want it like they're like
we want to help people like Ron you
don't need any money really to help
people like look I mean I I live in an
apartment now it's crazy to me that I
don't need a big house you know you grow
up you're like you know like you don't
need a lot of room with less room you
don't leave less stuff I don't need five
seventy inch TV screens I don't need a
wha I don't I don't even wear a watch I
don't need a cool watch I don't need to
I don't need a boat like I need the game
I know myself I need the game and that's
how I act other people what you know
things that they don't really need
things that aren't gonna make them happy
they're not fulfilled inside and so I'm
trying always challenge people to get to
their true self because once you
understand yourself
d-roc loves to tell stories in video
form and so like then do that
self-awareness says maybe you should be
number two number five number seven
number twelve maybe you should be an
accountant
not an entrepreneur you know because you
could become the CFO of an entrepreneurs
company and make a billion dollars
number 72 at Facebook made a lot more
money than number one of almost every
business that has come out in the last
ten years so there's just to me
self-awareness is what are you good at
what do you like what puts you in a
position to be successful I mean I have
some entrepreneur friends I have one
relative entrepreneur friends that I
think that they should be a full-time
mother I think she's making a huge
mistake she stinks the entrepreneur
she's incredible EQ and amazing
leadership and like I don't know like
you just don't need 90 year olds to talk
about how pumped they are that they made
an extra hundred thousand dollars like
they don't exist they talk about regret
of not doing what they would go talk to
nine year olds they regret they talk
about regret I wish I did literally
inevitably I'd do this I wish is the
opening line hey man tell me about your
life like this is what I do and this is
what I did in my 20s I spoke to a lot of
old people they lived it and surely I
wish one by one at airport at Airport
Park or Park event or event
bar or bar every one of them every one
of them all of them started with I wish
all of them I wish they grew up in a
generation that did not have the
Internet
it was not practical to do all the
amazing things we could be doing they
all wished they wish they worked harder
they wish they spend more time with
their family they wish they didn't
listen to their mom and did what they
wanted to do mine without
my mom didn't want to until you'd want
to let me go last day I keep on pushing
keep on cause you keep on pushing she
lets me know
they wished they wished they wished the
biggest poison in us is regret it's
poison and I push so hard so hard and
we'll through my vehicle which is a
meditation which isn't health and
wellness which is a non-profit my
vehicles business I can't help it it's
what I love I love building businesses I
love competing with you I want to beat
you I love that game but through that
vehicle I will always push a lack of
regret and awareness to how good it
really is you're more than welcome to
tell me about how bad it is or why you
can't because or what but it's just not
true because if anybody ever did it then
you can tell not peanuts in a pianist
that's cheese nuts
I should work yep what does that mean so
we're trying to find two different words
to describe but in some possible you
just left hustle and hustle you're gonna
try to establish yes in hustle eh it's
not a different version I like antics I
like it
and what do you mean by hustle was it
the visual possibly can be to me it's
it's a it's an adjective it's a word
that represents working hard and smart
competitively doing whatever it takes to
succeed to me Gary the book is now
available on Amazon India I just tweeted
it jacket and so I leave you with this
if you leave with anything tonight it's
stop making excuses stop complaining
nobody's listening they may make pretend
they're listening the market doesn't
care what you need to do is make one
person happy you then you can make
everybody else happy you know why I like
making people happy cuz I'm already
happy you know what's cooler than
anything I think talking big [ __ ] and
backing it up I think that's the coolest
and like I just I just think about when
our conversations what I'm like yeah
well Emily open London can't believe
like can't believe it's so real if we
did it
and so I implore you to take this last
little rant and really look at your
[ __ ] face and understand are you
doing the things that are putting you in
a position to succeed not just in a
business world but in life because it's
super important to build in vain the
world was a major success a sixth
interview legendary because boy when
you're happy in life your [ __ ]
business can roll and so I'm just trying
to figure it out and I've been trying to
figure it out in front of you for the
last seven eight years trying to figure
out the unlocks EQ IQ self-awareness
hustle I don't know what they are you
know why cuz like I took my man it's
three hundred thirty different unlocks
and so I'll go to all of them they're
all tried and true and one might hit you
yeah it was hard work cuz I'm actually
lazy a talk of your game but I'm full of
[ __ ] or it might be something else but
[ __ ] one one [ __ ] life one life my
friends one time and honestly I'll leave
you with this because a lot of you need
it how you make your money is more
important than how much you make